after nearly two years of hardships and
sudden changes in the classroom ccsd
employees could get some extra money for
all their hard work a tentative
agreement was announced today to give
out retention bonuses for full-time
staff sasha loftus spoke with a local
educator tonight who hopes there's more
support on the way sasha joins us live
tonight with more
brian ccsd educators have been through a
lot over the past few years the teacher
i spoke with tonight said she's happy
with any extra compensation but she
believes more needs to be done
it's been a tough road for ccsd
employees since the start of the kovid
19 pandemic we have every hand on deck
that we can or we're
combining classes special education
teacher dolly rowan says with the latest
omicron search the hits just keep coming
we are trying our best but we cannot
keep those schools sanitized those
kiddos are not keeping their mask on
district leaders announced thursday that
a tentative agreement was reached to
provide retention bonuses to full-time
employees i'm always grateful for extra
income but it's a little too little too
late according to a memo sent to staff
anyone who was working full time as of
january 1st will receive 1 thousand
dollars those still on the books by may
25th are eligible for another thousand
rowan says it's a start but it doesn't
begin to cover out of pocket costs over
the last two years once i've already
endured so many costs during the
pandemic she says she and others hope to
see more support as those working both
full and part time do their best to keep
our valley kids safe
dr jarrah and district staff are set to
propose this at the next regular board
meeting which is next thursday january
13th now the board of trustees will have
to approve this in order for ccsd staff
to receive this money reporting live in
the newsroom tonight sasha loftis live
local
now